meets the better say I've been given
authorization you make that before i do
that if i could seem diff for moment of
you I'm all the morality and the
decoration under this to be on the stage
and then with each step that's the very
long as there are no candidate the
thread family unity through out I am
period in particular during the day
local taking place and lastly by
suddenly least two rather than in
Campinas I to this referendum through
this evening of conducted themselves
with the quorum and a bit of credit to
their to complain the official
declaration I register baby coming up
sir appointed to the eigen local
government area at the scottish
independence referendum int be my
perfect i can declare wow the referendum
in angus is eighty thousand three
hundred suit the Turner's eighty five or
seven percent the total number of
attempted 566 and the reasons were or
again and we require 17 developing over
answers 45 for uncertainty the total
number of what I saw yes 30 2044 4100
that concludes the signature thank you
very much